business operations hubbled again this
week Universal Studios Resort in Beijing
was shut to comply with pandemic
controls it's the second time it's
closed because of covert curbs since
opening in September last year outbreaks
across the country have triggered a new
wave of lockdowns in cities including
guangzhiao Wuhan and here in the capital
for companies it's created ongoing
uncertainty but there's still plenty of
support for the government's zero covert
approach
because it's a stable policy society's
progressing swiftly and there is
prosperity everywhere investors don't
appear to share that sentiment a day
after China unveiled its new leadership
markets plummeted on Monday Hong Kong's
Hang Seng Index sank its furthest since
the 2008 Global financial crisis the
Yuan weakened to a 14-year low as people
weighed the prospects of prolonged
covert restrictions now there was always
an expectation that the polar Bureau
standing committee remember that China's
highest level of government would be
packed with individuals aligned with Xi
Jinping who has repeatedly defended his
zero covert policy but what was
disappointing for many people was that
wasn't even a hint of how the country
might move on from it
since Monday's Market melt down China's
Central Bank said it would keep Capital
Market steady bringing back some calm
there was a small sign of easing border
controls as well authorities sent from
this weekend China would boost
international flights by more than
double the current levels still totaling
only about 800 a week just a fraction of
pre-pandemic numbers but the increase of
flights is basically a message of we go
for virtually nothing to nothing it's
not really going to swing the needle in
particular as the world is not waiting
for China covert curbs have also kept
pressure on the country's indebted
developers home prices fell for a 13th
straight month in September according to
official data actually this is one of
the key areas that we would like to see
some news or or policy details on I
think it would definitely help it would
get some stability in terms of the uh
you know the the debt situation the
ability basically the ability for some
of the trouble companies to to get
access to Capital
many fear China's new leadership will
prioritize ideology over the economy but
for now it seems their biggest concern
may be a lack of any change in policy
Direction Patrick fock Al Jazeera
Beijing